the rain is moving on the tarps about to
come off we'll be playing some baseball
this afternoon tigers and minnesota
twins start a three-game
series let's get this moving let's get
it in this will be the first ever
career start for jose uranya against
minnesota
and it will be just his second career
start
at comerica park luis arise
is a terrific hitter
and arise it starts this series with a
base hit
an o2 pitch off the end of the bat
dropping safely into center field
and that is off ramos's glove and to the
backstop and the rise will go to second
base
and that is pulled into right field his
first hit of the year
and horizon will stop at third base
now the ball getting away from ramos
behind home plate
and a rise will score
[Music]
[Applause]
the ball retrieved by right fielder
mazzara
and he just threw it somewhere to the
infield it got by
the first baseman's scope and then
kicked away from
ramos that shoemaker his career versus
the tigers has been
very good he pitched for the blue jays
for a little while and uh
also pitched in the american league for
the angels and anaheim robbie grossman
looking for his first hit of the year
and that changeup gets another swing and
a miss one down
tap to the right side polanco
to cenone a quick first inning one two
three the tigers go down
and the twins are up there's ryan
jeffers
jeffers a former second round pick of
the twins waits on a 3-2
way out front strikeout number two for
arena
get away with the hanger so a four pitch
walk
third of the game second of the inning
first a
visit from the new pitching coach for
the tigers now here comes luisa rise
from the outfield and now it's three and
one
another three ball count going to get uh
some attention and now trainers are
going to come out a pectoral
muscle strain whatever it is it's calmed
down enough and
he has been convincing enough to michael
salazar and rocco baldelli
to stay in the game and there's ball
four
and that loads him up for polanco
and that hits slowly deflecting
apparently toward goodram and a run will
score
and now the dangerous nelson cruz
fly ball deep right field toward the
pole
but foul and cruz is pointing fair
and the first base umpire kerwin dadley
said foul
and a foul ball is confirmed rainier's
got a basis full situation nevertheless
and that one is hit hard to left that
ball's back and there's your grand
slam nelson cruz
making sure that one stayed fair
incredible
that's absolutely incredible he hits a
home run foul down the right field line
changes it up decides to throw him a
slider and once he do he hits it out the
left and that was an absolute missile
and there's your four runs right there
twins have a comfortable lead now
making them pay for all those free
passes that they were able to get
aquil badu what a story it was for him
yesterday weights on an 02. went too far
skipped away he's gonna have to hustle
down to first
and he will get there in time
got a steal here
but it was off inside the throw down to
second
not in time and badou
gets detroit in scoring position
i had a good jump there too you did you
had a great jump
well robbie swing and a miss
and grossman strikes out for the second
time and detroit goes
quietly in the third and here as
willians has to deal
left center field and deep and caught on
the warning track by grossman
retreating is simmons and he will get
back to the bag
2-1 lifted to deep left grossman's got
room
lockdown grossman good job gibby you
folded baby
[Music]
good first inning to work for buck
farmer but it's still six nothing twins
last time shoemakers started against the
tigers
it was that opening weekend series in
toronto
that was a splitter it's popped to right
good one
for max kepler and the tigers go in
order
again in the fourth matt shoemaker has
been really good
pitch up and in makes it two and one on
nelson cruz grand slam in the second
and now there goes another one
ramos asked for a new baseball before
cruz finished his swing
and he hit i mean the first one was a
line drive 20 feet off the ground this
was an absolute
bomb and very rarely do you see anyone
reach those that second
tier of seats there in left field at
comerica park and
this was a no doubter off the bat he
challenged him with a 3-1 fastball and
absolutely crushing so holland comes in
and
walks his first batter continuing to
just put people on base
simmons to the gap in left center field
down for a hit
grossman fields and two runs will score
so simmons
delivers another two out run producing
hit
ostidio drives one to right center field
and back goes mazzara
he won't get there
and jeffers will score and around third
and scoring is simmons and ostadio who
had a warning track fly ball
to left field in the fourth goes to the
warning track in right field for a
two-run double
we'll just tell you that matt shoemaker
right now is dealing
wilson ramos grounded to third his first
time up a year ago the 1-1
hammered to left get up get up and it's
gone
[Applause]
that breaks up the no-hitter in style
tigers are on the board listen rambos
the bullet could have pulled off it
stayed through it and it stays fair
well he's already homered three times in
a game
twice in his twins career and he has a
line out
a grand slam and a solo home run nelson
cruz will lead off the sixth
and a base hit down the line it'll be
another
extra base hit but it's in the ballpark
and cruz will glide into second
with a double kepler
that's a fair ball right down the line
and cruz
will come home and kepler trades places
with
nelson cruz sending him home and kepler
goes to second nice double against a
left-handed pitcher
ninth walk for the team today
here's jeffers to bat line drive that's
going to be a base hit to right field
nice job jeffers
garlic scores cenotes second
and another run now for the minnesota
twins they're up
13 to one kyle garlick at the plate
and garlic drives one to left field deep
to the corner
and high off the wall ostidio will score
garlic missed a home run by about a foot
and he's got a hit solid stroke to
left center field and a run batted in
garlic will score
and rooker went down and got that one
and drilled it to center field
that's a winning streak
to left center field and a diving catch
by rooker in left field
and rooker slow to get up hoping that he
just
knocked his wind out but a tremendous
catch by rooker in left center field
victor reyes drives one to deep right
that's gone
[Applause]
he has really good numbers against randy
dobnik
they've gotten even better now
base is loaded for akil badu
2-1 drifted to deep left field
way back are you kidding me the fairy
tale continues
a keel badou with a grand
slam in his second major league
game and the tigers
making things interesting here in the
ninth incredible this young man
15-6 twins lead